so who's my guest this week it's the
inventor of the world wide web sir tim
berners-lee
when it comes to computer science it
doesn't get much bigger than inventing
the web
not many developments have had such an
impact on the way we live and arguably
the way we think and behave
his former boss's initial description of
his idea as vague but exciting might
seem modest now but that's an indication
of the unforeseeable change it created
tim berners-lee has devoted his time to
advocating web freedom and access
through his worldwide web foundation
now he wants to challenge the power of
big organizations online and reassert
the web's original principles but is it
too late
here's a taste of what's coming up how
happy are you with the digital world
recent events including the pandemic has
heightened people's understanding out
there that this is
not just it's it's it is the internet is
a right but it's not something you can
take for granted we have to fight for it
when i've seen you you know when i've
been actually you know face to face with
you with your creation and there's only
one that really comes to mind which was
your cameo in the london 2012 olympic
games opening ceremony you were on stage
in a in an amazing looking sort of lit
up house and you look like you're typing
and then a message appeared across the
audience beamed across the audience
which said this is for everyone
how did that feel doing that and you
know being on that showcase it was
being amazing
so tim welcome to the programme it's
lovely to have you here and we're going
to come to your latest project very soon
but i wanted to to ask first of all is
it a burden being tim berners-lee the
man who invented the world wide web
i i wouldn't say it's a burden it
doesn't seem from my point of view to be
a burden uh in that
i'm not that famous for people
recognizing me in the supermarket
uh on on the other hand inventing the
world library means you do get invited
to all kinds of great dinners meet all
kinds of people so my life gets more
interesting just for that so i'm not a
burden and and i wonder for you
is there a pressure with it sometimes
because when i don't know if i was sat
next to you at a dinner and i asked you
what you do and you say of course what
you're working on now but oh i i happen
to invent this thing called the world
wide web and do you feel a pressure then
to talk about things you've done since
or how that compares i i've learned from
bitter experience that it's good idea to
say early on by the way i invented the
web 30 years ago but it's not that small
getting on the table uh rather than
spring it after five hours of
conversation uh so
that uh
but i think there's
certainly when we started the web
foundation there was a feeling that that
you can't just uh invent something when
it gets to the 20
the point that 20 of the world is using
it
then there is a
responsibility and so it wasn't just me
but all the people involved in making
the web more powerful realized that
every step they made the web more
powerful that gap in power between those
who had it and those who hadn't was
increased so the digital divide would
increase every time we made the web
better and so
that meant we had a the web foundation
was founded basically
partly on on simply
if 80 of the web at the time
of the world wasn't on the web then we
should the the other 20 had a duty
to get them on
work to get to them on and now it's more
than half the world as it is on the web
so it's saying we've got a lot of
momentum in that direction but yes i
think
there's a responsibility both for
getting the other people on but also
then particularly more recent years
realizing that it's not obvious that the
web would actually be 100 a good thing
and actually though you also have to
constantly be
looking for what could go wrong and and
what has gone wrong and what could be
fixed
how happy are you with the digital world
stepping back very much in general uh i
think you can't complain because and i
think
the pandemic i think has showed a lot of
people who didn't really think about it
beforehand that actually
uh you know if they have the internet
they can work from home if they don't
have the internet then they can't work
from home and then
maybe people also think a little bit
more about the fact that
there hasn't been very much such
censorship in the country where they
live but they look and they see that
people in other countries
have the internet blocked completely
during elections for example and so on
so i think that
recent events including the pandemic
have heightened people's understanding
out there that this is
not just it's it is the internet is a
right but it's not something you can
take for granted we have to fight for it
yes and the fight for the the rights of
information but also the correct
information free information not fake
news and not have that that layer on it
how do you think we're doing with that
because some would say the internet has
made things better in many ways but
worse on some of those fronts i think it
really depends on which system you're
talking about so different social media
systems are designed they work in
different ways you know you could like
things and the like buttons and the pro
sort of the workflow you go through to
encourage each other and
and and give feedback to each other is
different and it turns out they have
very different effects so it turns out
that early on feminist bloggers found it
being on twitter it was just horrible
for example and
so
other than uh the questions about being
on instagram if you're a teenage girl it
can be it can have psychological issues
just with the things that the platform
seems to
suggest that you should do that you have
to be
infinitely beautiful things like that so
these are all different platforms so
it's not the web as a whole it's it's a
question of the design
on top of that yeah so what i tell
people is looking you know
to start with
if you if you're a coder or whether or
not you're not a coder if you can
imagine a social network it works
differently and you think it would work
and you can imagine it would work it
would be a better place to be or maybe
you could imagine a social network which
uh where people would tend to be more
constructive where you tend to get more
truth out of it than on truth because
people be more collaborative and more uh
who have a better culture then
design that social network or go to the
people
that sounds like you believe design
could be the answer and that it can be a
better world can be baked into the
design rather than what some people say
which is uh these platforms reflect back
at us the societal ills so it's not the
platform's fault it's who we are and and
therefore they don't think the
technology company should do more for
instance to get rid of the toxicity that
many women find online i think that's
it's naive to imagine that in a way it's
simplistic to imagine that
things like twitter and facebook and
instagram
and so on and read it they're that they
are simple mirrors initially i think
when when the early
maybe sort of in the pre-web days when
people were using the internet to
exchange files the the meme was that the
internet is neutral there's humanity out
there is good and bad yes when you
connect to people you know you could
join them in an irc chat room back there
before the web and you will find good
and bad people uh but actually now
because we have these different
performances because they're different
actually no
where
the web foundation in fact did uh
did some studies and looked at
when they were looking at misogyny
online they were looking at gender
rights and online
gender violence and they found for
example three things where a social
media company could actually change the
way the system worked
and it would make it better for women
and they went to those
different companies and they
and they suggested it and the changes
were made and the web got better
so
there is a huge i'd like to feel some of
those changes that you're talking about
maybe yes maybe didn't they didn't fall
huge apples right next to you but uh but
the
message is really that no the way you
decide uh it is important yeah humanity
is important too
so when we you know we do
everybody needs to help so governments
need to help by
getting the laws in place of things that
are really really nasty nasty and
illegal are illegal yeah people need to
before they retweet something before
they like something they need to learn
to actually do a double take but would
you agree that it's gone it's going the
other way because i always envisioned
you know and i used to work as a
technology correspondent that our
offline sales and our online sales would
come closer as we got more used to using
these platforms we would try and not do
something online that we wouldn't do in
real life and yet we seem to have done
this we project an image of who we want
to be and because of people being able
to be anonymous they are doing different
things than they would do if they saw
you in the street so while you're you're
talking about when you say you talk
about people who may not understand
maybe you're talking about twitter uh
maybe you're not you're not talking
about or in the comments below
articles or on videos on this video you
know people can say whatever they want
but they wouldn't say it to your face i
think basically stepping back uh
each of these
the
the the things which go wrong with each
of these uh
spaces it depends on the way that
they're designed
that
uh
and there and in each case the issues
are different in each case you need to
do lots of research to understand
exactly how how the badness and the
goodness properly propagate so you can
maybe amplify the goodness of it so uh
yeah i i
still believe that
that
that being responsible online is part of
it and and also the way bill apps is
part of it you mentioned the world wide
web consortium of which you're a
director the the plan and the goal is
obviously to hold big tech companies to
account but there has been concern
because of how it's funded with big tech
helping to fund it that there is a
conflict of interest and i suppose
taking a step back
there is a concern about who marks these
few tech giants homeworks who does hold
them to account when we have so many
governments who aren't tech savvy at all
it's true that we need to get many more
many more coders into positions in into
parliament and into the judiciary so we
do didn't but uh but in but if you are
you asked particularly about the
wpcwc is a consortium of different
companies where there are huge companies
there are other big companies and there
are lots of startups and the big
companies there's everything in between
there are academics and academic
institutions and the non-profits and
they all meet and at the end of the day
every organization no matter what it
size gets
one vote so
you can't say so no matter how much
money people pour into it uh
that they might uh for example the
mobile
web initiative everybody wanted to get
the web onto mobile so because some
companies said yes we're gonna put my
money into this for the accessibility
web accessibility initiative some
companies specifically found that but
but there's a very very strong culture
but once the consortium has been funded
by its members then it operates as an
independent body which is independent
and i think that's a very valid point to
know about how it works but i suppose
i'm also asking a slightly bigger
question which is
do you have faith
in those big technology companies you
know the apples the googles the
facebooks i mean they've got different
parent names now but you know because
they own several several brands but just
use their household names do you have
faith that they can be brought to task
that they can be policed and and change
their behavior
i know that uh so i'm not going to talk
about the individual companies in
general and and so if you talk about big
companies then i know one thing i have
said
consistently is that there's always a
problem when something becomes a
monopoly whether it was netscape was the
only browser that you could buy and then
it was microsoft that you could buy and
uh
and so on so uh and when um
and so uh alta vista was the only search
engine and and so now it's uh so
whenever you do get a problem uh that
one company's dominating the space
that tends to be
the monopoly tends to mean it's not good
for innovation because you know that's
if you're just starting as another
company it's it's hard to imagine how
your ideas can have impact so
yes i think that you have so so in a way
there are always problems with
monopolies but although
the market system tends to take us
always naturally
towards that situation
then uh but the state of whether
individual i'm not going to go to
individual companies
to what extent i expect them to behave
better or worse in the future but
everybody's asking that question you're
not the only one you're the chief
technology officer of a company called
inrupt which has this new platform for
the web called solid what is it and what
are you hoping to do because part of
that is about changing people's behavior
so solid is if you like uh from the
point of view of inventing the web 30
years ago the web it's a it's a midpoint
correction to the web the web would look
to be uh people were very hopeful about
the web then
as it's continued for the second decade
then in the last decade it seems to
potentially be heading in place towards
all kinds of
of potential things that could go wrong
with humanity using technology connected
and so this is idea about wait a minute
what if we do some bit of a rethink for
example
when you work on with one social network
on one uh
one website
everything you down there gets stored
there all the photos all the likes get
stored there on flickr and if you're
flickr i've got my these photos and i
can't share it the the system doesn't
let me share my flickr photographs with
my linkedin colleagues and my facebook
friends because we haven't exported we
don't have interoperability between the
groups we have that we don't have the
ability of a google group to work in
facebook and solid is about saying okay
let's fix that so if you're logging this
we're solid then you have a solid id
which works
all across the web i can take
photographs i put them into my solid
storage into my solid pod we call it a
personal online database so that's what
you're calling them pods these digital
these digital pods
you know just want to try and imagine it
and so so
when you imagine it's like a
usb drive in the sky yes it's just a
space place you can put stuff and can
you actually do that you know these
walled gardens are set up because
they're making money that's how the
brands want them to be and a lot of
people conversely are happy to use them
because they're used to it now and they
think well this is how you use these pro
these platforms how are you going to
change behavior and and get people to
think like we're not going to wait for
everybody to change over immediately at
one point we're just going to start
people using as people use the solid
platform
enabling of people when people
realize that they spent a lot of time
working between different communities
for example then all we need is enough
people bit by bit
to start using it and to realize it's
better are you doing this because you're
frustrated with
how
how the digital world has become these
separate i i created the web because i
was frustrated but with how the digital
world was because then it was uh
you you had
you had documents sitting on disks the
disks on computers the computers were
connected to the internet uh but you
couldn't just click
it's a pretty great invention if i was
frustrated with something i just came up
with the world wide web because i was
annoyed about floppy disks so
uh well i can imagine that actually you
know it could be much more powerful i
could be i should be able to click
between these documents instead of
having to download them all separately
uh so you i love that i love it i love
that it was boring from that
i'm glad you like it go ahead
anytime be my guest no but regardless of
the platform you're actually just saying
to people think about this differently
think about your data think about how
you are being used yes
imagine how it is difficult with the web
it's difficult with the solids difficult
difficult it's a different it turns the
whole world of apps on sort of upside
down or right way up frankly so the
right way up is yeah of course every
time you do something so when you go to
you
go to have a vaccine
a vaccination
and you
or you
go for a run or you go to a gym and you
go to the gym and you log on to the
gadget and so
that it will be natural that you log on
with solid you give it your qr code
and you authenticate and you say yes
these devices in this gym can write all
my stuff
into my pot even then put it by [ __ ]
how are you going to cope if it doesn't
work are you good with failure the
developers around me are really excited
about it because for different reasons
it's really exciting because you're a
developer as well
and so uh
so i think that
uh that you know i would have been
accept that
so one way
uh one way of it growing for example
would be just we started people who just
continue to battle on to build a world
better world and bit by bit it grows but
uh but when we started the company
in fact
we've yes of course we've got interest
from developers uh well i'm sure
i'm sure if your name's on something
we've got a hundred thousand people
created it sort of pods very quickly but
just to fight
to try and understand uh what it was and
we got a company got interest from some
big
uh from
some big companies that realized that
they could if they used solid pod
technology they would be treating their
users better and they'd have a better
relationship with their users and their
they'd be empowering their users but
mainly we got incoming from governments
i wanted to ask you coming away from
your company you say this is a
mid-course correction i also like the
fact you describe yourself as a geek um
i i always like that people owning that
word um as a very positive thing but you
are you
thinking about also how do you think the
future of the digital world we live in
is going to change what do you think
that looks like you know people talking
you know is virtual reality is the
network going to be uh it's what you
know the whole the future and the answer
is well it's going to be part of the
future is going to be another piece
there was a time when the web the
internet wasn't really fast enough to
send movies and so movies weren't really
a thing but then bit by bit the
computers got faster than the networks
got faster and they just got bigger and
now movies are a big thing and if you
ever and so
ever so we're getting with vr we're
getting new media
it'll be interesting how i think you'll
be able to set between you're being a
slip between a movie in the vr world of
that movie for example really
that's why i hope yeah i hope that we'll
be able to uh
for example
maybe we should uh have a future version
of this conversation in the vr world
where we can see each other really well
just like like we can
where we're not actually physically face
to face uh but then
although i've missed this the pandemic
meant that i have done so many of my
interviews not face to face yeah i don't
want to do what you've just described
although it sounds amazing but the a lot
of the core of whether we meet in vr
whether
or whether we meet
uh through video or or face to face
the things we decide on if we're in our
meeting the things the events that we
agree on in the future uh those those
will be stored that data which is uh
data which will we will be
be able to use much more effectively i
think also will appear but
hopefully
as we've as the the revolution of yeah
of personal empowerment flips the world
back right upside down when you have
control of your data one of the
interesting things that comes out of
this is an ai that works for you
talk to you and you talk to your current
ai so siri who do you work for alexa who
do you work for uh
if they're they're honest actually it's
not you
uh but imagine china never asked siri
that question what would it say
i uh
i think
uh i i started i would have said i
worked for steve jobs but now it'll say
i guess we will for apple uh
have you ever asked another question
it's a good one i i think i have but
uh but imagine you have a charlie
where charlie says actually i work for
you
uh charlie says you know uh you paid for
me uh i you
you trust me with all with
all your information just a final
thought if i can i am i was thinking
when i've seen you you know when i've
been actually you know face to face with
with you with your creation and there's
only one that really comes to mind uh
which was your cameo in the london 2012
olympic games opening ceremony and for
those who haven't seen it obviously
millions did you were on stage in a in
an amazing looking sort of lit up house
and you look like you're typing and then
a message appeared across the audience
beamed across the audience which said
this is for everyone uh how did that
feel doing that and and you know being
on that showcase it was
being amazing it was absolutely
incredible
such a privilege to be i mean
to be asked to to sit in the that
stadium with uh i mean to be part of the
the crew
for the opening ceremony of the of the
olympics was uh was you know all
volunteers uh a few total stars total
stars that i'd uh really respected and
you can meet backstage and and then when
i was in that before the
the
uh there's a house around the house
and before it lifted up i was sitting
there and i had to flatten myself
against the back wall of the house
because all thousands of dancers they've
been dancing all wearing different
costumes all they'd all been were
dancing different dances and they all
left the entire stadium
came flocking and they all went in
through the door of the house and they
can summon them they all knew where to
go and i was standing against
they could go left or right and up and
down and they all had to disappear and
they so they
came running incredibly excited they
just had the dance of their lives yeah
and their and they'd express their
individuality and but also their common
you know the commonality of working
together on the uh they're on the
opening ceremony and the commonality
working together for olympic games so
that was just
amazing incredible
well and such a powerful message you
know this is for everyone what you
created that must have given you an
amazing feeling
tim vanzelli sat sir tim berners-lee
thank you so much for talking to me
the pleasure is mate and thank you so
much for being with us uh until we meet
again
stay safe goodbye
[Music]
you